welcome back tina brown is the former
editor-in-chief at tatler magazine
vanity fair and the new yorker 15 years
ago tina released the diana chronicles
dubbed a profound and in-depth look at
princess diana's life and death now her
new book the palace papers inside the
house of windsor tackles the highs and
lows of the royal family including the
controversy surrounding the duke of york
and harry and megan's infamous move to
the u.s
tina thanks for coming on the show and
um and thanks for sending us a copy of
this and i have been uh kept up very
late at night reading it because it's
genuinely
a really good read
and it's a page-turning drama really of
the ups and downs of the past two
decades of of of royal life
and it struck me when i was reading the
book that after diana
the queen effectively said
never again will one member of the royal
family destabilize the whole institution
like the way
diana and that whole situation did
and then i thought of prince harry and
andrew and it seems to me that they've
been having quite a good go at
destabilizing the institution and the
queen
well that's right and in a different way
i mean diana's destabilization was
because she became bigger almost than
the institution which was something that
had never encountered before
in the case of uh you know andrew and
harry of course uh
andrew was a was a was an explosion
waiting to happen frankly the way he'd
been carrying on decade after decade
really kind of unpoliced in a sense
about what he was getting up to so that
exploded as it inevitably would frankly
um
harry was i think the real uh
kind of unsettling surprise
in a way harry has sort of continued
his mother's legacy essentially of
throwing hand grenades
and i think that's what they found so
destabilizing about harry's they don't
quite know when another one of the the
guns is going to go off which is what
we've been seeing really ever since the
la well for the last four or five years
and i was going to come on to harry and
megan in a bit but more broadly when you
think about
the monarchy which you've studied for
many many years and britain
it it seems that the monarchy is able to
adapt and it has this ability to survive
is it
is it rather like the terminator it's a
sort of something that's indestructible
do you think
it is or is proven to be in the sense
it's lasted for a thousand years
but we are at a perilous moment i think
in this particular this particular time
because
a lot of the uh dramas of the last 25
years i wrote about were somehow
the queen at the center was always this
still center of composure in the storm
in the storm she was always going to
sort of pull it together and pull it out
the difference now of course is we have
a very frail queen in the last twilight
years of her life and there won't be her
as the composure at the center to pull
the institution around and keep on
representing it with the same kind of
gravitas so
uh that's much more concerning i think
now that the rocking and the boat
somehow can be
uh quelled for a while while
king charles when she will be you know
takes over and tries to that would be a
big danger point you think in the
monarchy's survival
i think it's a very very um
unsettled point and
charles is going to have quite a
challenge i think in sort of calming all
the troubled waters and
i think personally that the british
people will actually rally to charles
because uh you know
there's a desire i think for this
institution to continue there hasn't
been really any great
potent lobby in england to get rid of
the monarchy
but it has been uh tarnished a great
deal by these last few years and charles
is going to have to figure out how to
sort of start to really modernize the
monarchy more than it has been and also
to to find a way to to kind of keep
those
uh troubles that have been assailing
them at bay
i want to go through the women now with
you briefly camilla
i mean in the book what you described
really is this turn around for her that
over the decades
she's gone from this sort of villainous
comedy character to someone who's
accepted if not quite loved by the
public
what genius was behind this
rehabilitation of her or rather was it
just in your view the passage of time
well there was a lot of of genuine
professional efforts behind camilla's
rehabilitation mark bolland you know who
was the communications secretary for
charles right after the the uh end of
the camilla the end of the diana era
just as that was ending he came in and
he spent many a year
carefully strategizing the sort of
emergence of camilla but i it was always
a question i think not only of strategy
and how she emerged but once people came
to understand who camilla really was as
opposed to how she'd been demonized that
ultimately that final acceptance is
camilla's triumph because
people who get to know camilla who
really see camilla up close love camilla
so that was really i suppose what
charles knew he knew if only people knew
her like i know her they wouldn't have
the hostility to her so you know it's
been wonderful to see that i think and
you portray her in a very positive light
in the book as you do with kate kate
middleton the duchess of cambridge
kate middleton is very much the hero of
your book
and you've spoken about the immense good
luck william had in finding kate and as
you just said has become the rock of the
family
in the book you write of her serene
empathy as you put it in sort of saving
william
does she have any edges at all is there
any
flawlessness in this character or is she
perfection
no one is perfection and i think that
the the what i hear is that the kate in
private is a much more relaxed loose
warm you know joshing kind of fun girl
woman
but she just has decided that the
best way for her to present to the
public is in a sense by taking a leaf
out of the queen's book and presenting a
certain kind of inscrutability and she
she's very savvy in understanding at a
much more difficult time than the queen
frankly experience because when the
queen was in her early years the press
was completely a deferential i mean
there was no expose of going on behind
the scenes so she but in in this age
she's dealing with a much more invasive
press but she's found a way to kind of
control her image if you like in a very
smart way as any kind of major movie
star does so she's very savvy at kate
and not i don't think quite acknowledged
for being quite the sophisticated
strategist that she is
what strikes me in the book though too
is let's come on to megan
there's a sense of disdain for megan i
pick up in this book and and it left me
with the impression that that you think
she's rather spoiled is that
is that fair tina well i don't think i
actually don't think that there is a
disdain for megan in the book i i feel
that i
i i
i actually
understand
uh
why she she she reacted as she did
how extraordinarily difficult it was for
an outsider an american to come into
this
sort of tight uh uh arcane family with
all of its traditions and its history
and it was an absolutely uh for her sort
of impenetrable experience
um
i think that she just didn't
realize as i think a lot of americans
certainly don't realize that actually
the royal way of life is nothing like
the celebrity way of life it's nothing
like the light you're like a royal or
you're a celebrity yes nothing like it's
nothing like that the california
elites way of life it's nothing i mean
it's it's it's actually they live you
know in a very unflashy way their their
vacations are
you know uh
in the rain often having tramping around
you know having picnic now outdoors this
is not anything in a sense that is as
glamorous i think or as it's exciting or
as desirable as uh most people on the
outside looking at the glitter and
glamour of being a princess they're not
seeing that they're not seeing quite
frankly the kind of frugal threadbare
aspect of the existence tina when you
think of that couple now and speaking to
lots of people you spoke to dozens of
people for this book um
do you think that they uh can come back
to the royal family do you think there's
a way back for them i mean some of the
things that you
count you know
it feels like maybe it's it's
irreversible these rifts it does at the
moment
but i tend to feel there will be a
desire to have the sussexes back
if something can be worked out where the
sussexes are happy and a role can be
found that they can do
i think that really because i after the
death of the queen there is going to be
such a huge seismic public reaction
there's going to be you know a sense
that that of of tearing of the fabric of
this country
with the passing of the queen who for 70
years has been the only thing we know
she's on the money even
um that i think that uh there will be a
desire to have the sussex back just
because they bring
a connection to the younger
part of this nation i know harry was the
most popular member of the royal family
and to have a a a beautiful you know
dynamic uh woman of color at his side
was actually a fantastic thing
uh for for for britain it really was and
there was a sense of great loss actually
there in the palace that that it didn't
work out uh the question is whether
megan will ever want to come back i was
going to say you can see harry may be
coming back but it's hard it's hard to
imagine it's hard to imagine megan will
want to come back after everything
that's passed but you know time passes
and it's quite possible that this this
entertainment deals that they've done
are going to not be as
glittering as
you know as they as they expect could
you see a situation where harry comes
back and megan does not that i i guess i
stick an impression no i i think that
this marriage i mean i think you know
that this is harry is devoted to her and
to the children so i don't i don't know
how it could happen but you know the
fact is that if you're a member of the
royal family you can be as boring as you
like forever and you're still going to
be at the top of the bill if you're in
an entertainment world you have to earn
uh you know your place in it by having a
hit and that's very hard to accomplish
but the next hit's going to be the
memoirs
prince harry's memory was
in september harry has how damaging
could that because you say there's a way
back and i think
the the comments about kate making megan
cry i mean those things kate can't reply
to but must cut her quite deeply the
memoirs come out what does what more
revelations could happen i think that
you know your original question can they
come back i think that one of the
questions is what what is said in this
memoir
and
that's the part that everyone finds in
the family finds very hard to understand
why harry has done that because
to have that hanging over them as a kind
of thing hanging out there of like what
is he going to say you know just at a
point when the queen is at her most
fragile
i think there's a huge anxiety about it
that was the other question i had about
the other person that does all doesn't
come back uh prince
andrew
obviously he escorted the queen at
prince philip's memorial service but is
there any way back for him or once the
queen isn't there anymore his
relationship with charles is very
fractious is that it for him
i don't think there's a way back for
andrew i really don't i think that
andrew thinks there's a way back for
andrew but i do not think there is a way
back for andrew and
i think that charles
will have to spell that out
even more clearly
than it has been spelled out thus far
uh to see him escorting his mother at
prince philip's memorial
was something that nobody liked the
sight of it it felt so unfortunate this
person so recently disgraced was had
sort of
managed to get himself into a position
where he was right right away before the
cameras escorting the most uh revered
and a woman in the world the love the
queen has for her son
the queen uh at this point in her life i
mean it is her son and she loves her
family and she's always found a way to
sort of differentiate between herself as
sovereign and herself as a mother and a
grandmother and sometimes that for her
has proved very very painful because she
said that things become in conflict i
mean she she was ultimately had to deny
her sister margaret uh
you know the the the the love of her
life peter town in but when it comes
down to protecting the crown she's
always done that one final question for
you
we are as you said drawing towards the
end of the queen's reign
she has
lived longer than millions and millions
of her subjects most of us can't imagine
a world where she isn't there she almost
symbolizes britain and what britishness
is
how traumatic do you think it will be
for the country when
queen elizabeth is is no longer there
i think it will be
an absolutely pivotal moment in this
country i think that
the mourning will be intense and
not only for this remarkable woman and
what she's been able to do
in her life for every day of her life
but also for a way
a way of britishness perhaps that she's
always epitomized
she has come to stand i think for all
the values that this nation holds dear
you know stoicism a sense of duty uh a
sense of fairness um a sense of doing
the right thing and to lose that i think
is going to be a traumatic event
well i think we're all dreading that
moment actually tina thank you so much
thank you beth um and i as i said i have
thoroughly enjoyed um this book which i
haven't quite finished because it's it's
big but it's good thank you for reading
i'm going to get through it thanks
thanks for coming thank you thank you so
much